I think the way to look at literature is as
an instrument that sensitizes us to different
things.
We all know that if five different people
are asked to describe one scene, they will
all describe it differently.
Some will describe the light, others will
focus on what people's feet were doing, others
will look at the, you know, material, shape
of the room or whatever.
A great writer picks up on those things that
matter.
It's almost like their radar is attuned to
the most significant moments.
What literature is about is a record of people
with very sophisticated radars who are picking
up on the really important stuff.
The interesting thing is that, for me, that
radar is not something we should simply passively
accept while we read the book.
It's something we should learn from.
We should shut the book and then say, "Okay,
I've read Jane Austin or Proust or Shakespeare
and now I'm going to see my mother or I'm
going to have a chat with my aunt or I'm going
to go and, you know, talk to some friends
in a coffee shop, and rather than just doing
it the normal way, I'm going to look at them
and I'm going to ask myself that basic question,
'how would Jane Austin see them?
How would Proust see them?
How would Shakespeare see them?'"
In other words, I'm not just going to look
at the world of Shakespeare or Jane Austin
through my eyes, I'm going to look at my world
through their eyes.
That is the benefit that is the intelligence
giving power of great literature.
We are sensitized by the books we read.
And the more books we read and the deeper
their lessons sink into us, the more pairs
of glasses we have.
And those glasses will enable us to see things
that we would otherwise have missed.